caroline paris bonjour je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu favorablement à notre
invitation
alors nous allons parler de ce livre qui
est super intéressant c'est l'enfant
stressé alors c'est vous qui l'avez
écrit je rappelle que vous êtes
intervenante psychosociale et vous
abordez dans une problématique qui
concerne la société dans son entièreté
bien pourquoi vous êtes vous intéressé à
cette thématique là mais en fait ça fait
maintenant dix ans que je travaille
auprès des jeunes et des familles puis
le stress et l'anxiété est une
problématique que je rencontre
régulièrement et je crois certains
moments qu'on sous-estimé l'ampleur des
symptômes des manifestations de la façon
ça peut venir perturber le quotidien de
l'enfant
donc j'ai jugé nécessaire d'en parler d'
approfondir le sujet mais surtout de
parler à la fois et aux parents et aux
intervenants en milieu scolaire pour
qu'on arrive les interventions qu'on ait
une vision de l'enfance plus cohérente
ensemble pour adopter des interventions
qui vont être vraiment très dense pour
l'enfant alors j'imagine que vous les
aidez surtout à comprendre différents
comportements qui peuvent intervenir
chez un enfant au courant d'une journée
d'entériner contentant tous les
mécontents un autre coup il n'est plus
du tout concentré à l'école
donc c'est des sautes d'humeur qu'on
n'arrive pas toujours à maîtriser
alors comment arrivez vous vraiment à
faire je dire à susciter vraiment la
compréhension des parents et des
enseignants par rapport à une thématique
aussi compliqué sa famille c'est
compliqué mais ça on sera menée à la
base le stress il est normal et les
nécessaires en fait pour bien
fonctionner mes écrans de trop de stress
convient il devient handicapant il avait
perturbé le quotidien
donc c'est derrière comprend que
l'enfant ne pas un cerveau qui est
mature donc il n'est pas en mesure de
gérer l'ensemble des demandes qui sont
faits dans son environnement
donc il devient réactif et on voit un
enfant qui adoptent des comportements
inconscients impulsif non volontaire de
par réaction de stress
donc oui à la fois il va devenir son
opposant et dans la confrontation
d'arguments thé où il va refuser de
mettre à la tâche il va progresser il va
faire des crises de larmes et crises de
colère donc c'est d'arriver à voir que
je suis chaque comportement de l'enfant
il ya une fonction et c'est d'arriver à
comprendre quelle est la fonction de
comportement là on va venir apaisé
l'enfance
crise et c'est d'abord ce qui le besoin
pour éventuellement l'amener à adopter
des comportements qui sont plus adéquats
plus efficace pour son quotidien
mais comme je les ai dit d'entrée de jeu
le stress est une problématique qui est
très très complexe alors est ce qu'il ya
une différence ou des similitudes entre
le stress chez l'enfant et le stress
chez l'adulte
en fait le stress et le maine le cerveau
penser la même chose donc il faut se
rappeler par contre nous ne fonctionnons
encore comme si nous étions dans la
nature ne tire vous fait pas la
distinction entre strasser qui est
réelle comme l'attaqué d'un ours par
exemple et le stresseurs qui imaginez
donc un examen un patron qui elle
talonne est le trafic donc et célimène
chez nous toujours des réactions de
stress que l'adulte gère davantage on
canalise mieux le stress parce que notre
cerveau est davantage mature mais le
stress reste le même pour tous une
semaine tous dans des mécanismes de
défense on n'est pas en mesure de le
gérer de gérer la demande à laquelle
nous sommes excusés
j'imagine que dans les ouvrages je vous
donnais quand même quelques pistes pour
aiguiller les pardons sur la meilleure
façon de gérer le stress chez leurs
enfants
oui je reviens toujours et c'est
important d'avoir sécurisé l'enfant faut
pas qu'on fait régulièrement c'est
d'adressé le comportement de l'enfant
alors que son message est inadéquat
c'est sa façon maladroite de nous dire
ce qu'il a besoin
donc moi toujours revenons à l'essentiel
revenons à l'émotion de l'enfant parce
que c'est en le sécurisant convoi
l'amener à adopter des meilleurs
comportements des comportements plus
adéquat et gît toujours aux parents
intervenants de en intervenant sur le
comportement on ne va pas aider l'enfant
gérer ses émotions
alors que si on était revenu sur les
émotions on voit les d'éventuellement
gérer ces comportements et comment doit
intervenir chez les émotions par exemple
d'abord aider l'enfant à reconnaître ce
qu'il est en train de vivre
donc quand il est dans son explosion de
colère qui devient un poli ou ou kylie
brusque avec elle son matériel scolaire
par exemple mais c'est de lui dire
simplement lorsque tu lance son objet
lorsque tu élèves le temps je crois que
tu es en colère
est ce que c'est ça est ce que tu es
décourager de vente en examen est-ce que
tu as par heure donc c'était de le
ramener à qu'est ce qui se passe en moi
qui m'amène à l'exprimer de cette façon
là donc de valider les émotions d'enfant
mais surtout de les normaliser de c'est
normal de vivre des émotions comme ça
c'est normal d'être découragé quand on a
des difficultés c'est normal
repart de thé paris de papa ou maman
donc ça c'est normal c'est justifie pas
le comportement en un sens on ne
souhaite pas qu'on va nous créer après
ou lancer chaude mais sale explique
davantage
donc si on peut être intelligent ma
façon d'aborder le comportement de
l'enfant
on va voir un enfant beaucoup moins
réactif parce qu'il va sentir que il
peut se poser sur l'adulte qui
l'accompagnent vous le dites également
dans l'ouvragé le stress affecte les
performances scolaires de l'enfant et
donc comment l'accompagner sur ce chemin
là comment faire en sorte qu'ils
travaillent mieux à l'école en fait
effectivement un enfant qui qui est
stressé va être une bagarre de la
difficulté attentif concentré parce que
son attention est rivé sur l'objet de
passer le pas par exemple d'échouer si
son parrain est en plein divorce il est
en déménagement donc son attention doit
être redirigé vers menace là plutôt que
sur madame josée par exemple qui est en
train de faire l'enseignement en avant
donc encore la même chose on va
sécuriser l'enfant
on va l'amener à s'il refuse de faire la
tâche site pendant l'examen avait une
crise de larmes mais des fois c'est de
prendre et je sais que c'est difficile
pour l'enseignant parce qu'il fait une
plusieurs enfants dans la classe mais
c'est nécessaire de prendre un temps
avec lui pour lui dire ce qu'il est en
train de vivre l'aider à vivre son
émotion
on ne veut pas distraire l'enfant de son
émotion on veut qu'ils apprennent à la
gérer et la meilleure façon c'est de la
bordée de la comprendre de lui refléter
dans l'ouvragé je vous introduisez
également une dimension ludique pour
accompagner l'enfant comme la danse les
activités récréatives avec lui quelle
est l'importance de cette dimension là
dans la prise en charge de la condition
de cet enfant mais en fait on pour tous
que l'enfant fait si c'est fait dans le
plaisir c'est beaucoup mieux en fait ils
veulent apprendre davantage ils veulent
intériorisé donc le plaisir est
nécessaire dans l'interface sont l'amour
est nécessairement l'intervention auprès
d'enfants mais je parle oui
effectivement de la dimension du sport
de bouger en fait les toutes les
activités
dix sportives sans nécessairement
s'inscrire au hockey ou s'inscrire à la
danse et au quotidien on doit amener
l'enfant à bouger le plus souvent
possible parce qu'en bougeant on vient
solliciter le système de détente de
l'enfant donc on la merde à diminuer son
niveau de stress
donc c'est très important et tout le
stress qu'ils accumulent au courant de
la journée va être éventuellement devoir
est utilisé et le stress est une
illustration lesparre et est une
merveilleuse façon de le faire mais il
est davantage question aussi de mettre
l'enfant confiance de lui apprendre à
gérer son stress
oui oui absolument puis c'était le
girondine en plus on va apprendre à
l'enfant à le reconnaître connaître
lycée mousse et des tentures mal au
ventre quand tu sens et tour dit quand
des mains deviennent moi c'est une
réaction normale
ça s'appelle du stress grâce et une part
de ce qui va se passer tu est inquiet et
ton corps te parle donc maintenant
partir qu'on me dise in comme ça qui
nous permet de reconnaître ça veut dire
prends soin de toi de quelle façon je
peux tu apprendras prendre soin de toi
moi comme a dit je vais prendre soin de
toi aussi
j'ai une grande part de responsabilité
mais maintenant je vais te saigner
certains trucs pour tes dont la
respiration la médication le sport voix
de l'enfant
quand il reconnaît le sens pas je vais
allez bouger je vais courir un peu
durant la récréation ça va m'aider à
diminuer mon niveau de stress donc faire
prendre conscience à l'enfant dès le
plus jeune âge dit c'est normal de vivre
du stress et maintenant comment on
s'adapte à ce stress là on va parler au
présent de vous car league
c'est quelque chose qui est toujours
difficile à faire je sais alors dites
moi pourquoi vous êtes vous intéressé à
une telle problématique
en fait comme je disais plus tôt c'est
je le rencontre régulièrement j'ai
travaillé avec une clientèle très
diversifiée dans les dix dernières
années j'ai travaillé en milieu scolaire
en milieu hospitalier dans plusieurs
organismes communautaires auprès des
jeunes en difficulté des jeunes la rue
des jeunes comme un trouble de santé
mentale déficience intellectuelle
puis dans chacune des clientèles avec
lesquels j'ai travaillé je remarquais
percevaient des symptômes de stress et
je me rendais compte que lorsqu'on
modifie l'environnement de l'enfant
qu'on prend conscience de ses besoins
mais les symptômes se résorbe compte
parfois complètement
donc je me dis il faut faire attention
quand on adresse des difficultés de
l'enfant savoir est-ce qu'en modifiant
l'environnent
l'accompagnant en choisissant des
interventions qui vont lui permettre de
se poser est ce que c'est possible qu'on
modifie son quotidien pour le mieux et
les réponses ont été mis constamment je
me suis intéressé au stress et l'anxiété
et par la force des choses les gens se
sont intéressés à moi pour aider les
jeunes à accompagner au niveau de stress
et de l'anxiété
tout à fait disons c'est un ouvrage qui
est très très riche qui va puiser dans
différents registres
on va dans le domaine de la santé oms va
en sociologie on va aussi cologie est ce
que vous avez eu à je sais pas où on a
demandé l'avis des spécialistes de ces
différents secteurs pour pouvoir
concocter votre ouvrage aurait
absolument le premier j'ai écrit le
premier jet et ensuite je me sens
entouré de partenaires très tellement
généreux en fer en neurosciences passer
du docteur joël monzée par exemple que
soutenu toute l'écriture de chapet nous
devons du cerveau j'ai eu le dr sonia
lupien ici est toujours un docteur en
neurosciences qui est qui et la
directrice fondatrice du centre d'études
sur le stress humain
donc j'ai une ergothérapeute et patricia
qui m'a aidé 2 nutritionniste stéphanie
cause être des des enseignants tous et
une directrice d'école
donc j'étais chercher un peu les les
intervenants qui gravitent autour de cet
enfant là parce que je sais très bien
que c'est en travaillant tous ensemble
qu'on va être en mesure d'aider l'enfant
est d'adapter au mieux son quotidien
pour qu'ils soient en mesure de de
s'accomplir de grandir de se développer
et il faut également souligner que sur
le plan intellectuel vous êtes très très
bien outillé pour rédiger un ouvrage
aussi complet et aussi jeudi inspirant
pour les parents et pour les enseignants
parlez nous un peu de votre parcours
universitaire enfin j'ai fait un
baccalauréat par association de 3 g donc
j'ai été chercher plus que ce que moi
j'avais besoin ce qu'est ce qu'ils
rejoignaient personnellement donc j'ai
pas le certificat en psychologie
sociologie sertic en intervention auprès
des jeunes et un certificat également en
santé mentale donc à travers ce parcours
là j'ai surtout eu l'occasion de
travailler dans différents milieux ou où
l'expérience terrain a été tellement
gratifiant tellement instructive et avec
des professionnels qui ont été très
généreux
avec moi donc ça me permet vraiment de
développer mes connaissances sur le
terrain de voir de quelle façon
maintenant on vous lit la théorie et la
pratique
mais je vous dirais que là le meilleur
terrain d'apprentissage a été mon rôle
de maman
maintenant le les enjeux de d'appliquer
les interventions mais notre propre
famille tout à fait les meilleures
connaissances
maintenant on est animé par nos propres
émotions et parfois encore été retenue
c'est ça et je vais me reprendre
mais oui c'est sûr que si on nous sommes
tous des parents moi aussi j'ai un petit
garçon qui vient d'avoir onze ans mais
voilà voilà caroline
une dernière question pour conclure là
c'est vraiment pour les parents à
l'attention des parents on va revenir
sur les symptômes du stress - del
reconnaître en fait il y en a il y en a
plusieurs
au niveau physique on va se rendre
compte mais l'enfant d'abord on va
réagir un peu la face on réagira devant
un autre dans la forêt donc une cave
accélérer notre cardiaque
on va voir être d'avantagé connecte à
mon sens à nos sens sont séduits y est
en stand gestique va ralentir ça va
emmener souvent des constipations chez
les enfants des mots de vendre des
douleurs à l'estomac
donc les douleurs que les inconforts que
les enfants rapporte sont réels et on se
sent parfois est ce que l'enfant utilise
les mots pour s'éviter des situations
mais les mots sont physiques sont réels
et on va voir ensuite toutes sortes de
les perceptions qui vont éternue on va
voir un enfant qui est à discuter à se
mettre à la tâche à la débuter elle a
complété un enfant qui va attendre la
dernière minute pour faire quelque chose
qui lui demande un effort mental tout
new qui est inquiétant pour lui que
difficile au niveau comportemental on
veut voir toute heure direction
d'enfants qui s'opposent qui confronte
l'enfant qui m'a aussi fait des crises
de colère dont vont voir toutes sortes
de symptômes et ces deux là je me dis ça
y est on veut pas devenir un spécialiste
en veux pas faire des parents des
spécialistes non guide quand votre
enfant vous rapporte des difficultés
plutôt que de tenter rapidement de
traiter ces difficultés-là de vendée
vous quel est le besoin en dessous
qu'est ce que son corps ou sa tête et ça
ne me dit
à quels besoins d'enfants essaie de
répondre par tel ou tel comportement
et là on se trompe pas comparé de la
source comment faire la différence entre
ce sont aux menaces et signe là est le
signe du tdah par exemple en fait très
similaires je peux pas dévoiler son
diagnostic est offert aux palets
d'agnostiques mais ce que je me rends
compte par contre dans le quotidien
c'est que oui va avoir des symptômes qui
sont très similaires
mais lorsqu'on choisit d'intervenir
auprès de l'environnement de l'enfant de
t'être dans la relation avec lui on
intervient directement qui leur étaient
des arches ou pas qu'il est un trouble
de position ou pas en adressant la cause
en revenant à la sécurité de l'enfant
on ne se trompe pas et bien voilà
c'était dans le caroline carey qui est
intervenante psychosociale et qui a
rédigé cet ouvrage formidable l'enfant
stressé ou est ce qu'on le trouve
caroline en fait il est disponible dans
les librairies chez tous les renaud bray
sur mon site web également triplé w
pazzapa point ca et chez septembre
éditeur également en tout cas je vous le
recommande vivement
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup au revoir